hagamos algunos ejemplos utilizando lo
que recién hemos aprendido de triángulos
equiláteros isósceles lo que tengo aquí
es un triángulo dentro de otro triángulo
y lo que quiero saber es cuánto mide
este ángulo de naranja que está aquí así
como este azul que se encuentra acá y lo
que sabemos es que el segmento ave es
igual al segmento bs que es igual al
segmento c de o también le podemos
llamar de c y lo primero que podemos
observar es que el triángulo abs es
isósceles y por sheri sociales los
ángulos de la base deben de ser
congruentes este lado es igual a este
otro lado por lo que los ángulos deben
ser congruentes por lo que el ángulo que
está aquí tiene que ser también de 31
grados y si sabemos dos ángulos de un
triángulo podemos conocer el tercero
porque los tres deben de sumar 180
grados
así que 31 grados más 31 grados más la
medida del ángulo abc
es igual a 180 grados y si restamos de
ambos lados 62 porque estos dos suman 62
obtendremos que la medida del ángulo a
bs será igual a 180 menos 62 180 menos
62 es 2 para 10 son 8 y llevo 16 y 17
para 18 son 11 118 este ángulo mide 110
y 8 grados y este otro ángulo es
suplementario al de 118 grados así que
118 grados más la medida de este ángulo
debe resultar 180 por lo que debe de ser
de 62 grados porque 62 más 118 es igual
a 180 este ángulo es de 62 grados ahora
este ángulo es un ángulo de la base del
triángulo b c b yo no lo había dibujado
de esta manera pero este lado y este
otro son congruentes la longitud de bc
es igual a la abc de estas son las dos
piernas de un tren
y sociales y podrías verlo como que está
de cabeza
este es el vértice y los ángulos de la
base son congruentes por lo que debe de
medir 62 grados así que si ahora
queremos saber el valor del ángulo azul
volvemos a utilizar que los tres deben
de sumar 180 grados por lo que 62 más 62
más el ángulo azul la medida del ángulo
dsd tiene que ser igual a 180 grados
veamos estos 2 62 más 62 resulta 124 y
restando 124 de ambos lados obtenemos la
medida del ángulo bsd es igual a bueno
si restamos 120 de 180 tenemos 60 y
después restamos 4 más
entonces obtenemos 56 56 grados
ahora resolvamos cualquiera de estos a
ver empecemos por este así que cuál es
la medida del ángulo ave
pues aún no he trazado el segmento b
pero voy a dibujarlo para ustedes así
que tenemos que calcular la medida del
ángulo ave y tenemos muchos lados
congruentes por aquí podemos observar
que el triángulo a vd tiene todos sus
lados iguales es un triángulo equilátero
y todos sus ángulos miden 60 grados
todos son iguales y mide cada 160 grados
y esto forma parte del ángulo ave y
ahora tenemos que resolver este otro
ángulo que está de este lado y podemos
identificar un triángulo isósceles de d
aquí está su vértice este es un ángulo
de la base y este es el otro ángulo de
la base el ángulo del vértice es de 90
grados y es un triángulo isósceles
porque el segmento bd es igual al
segmento d
y una vez más la suma de estos dos
ángulos con el del vértice tiene que ser
180 grados le llamaremos x le llamaremos
x así que x más x más 90 grados serán
igual a 180 grados así 12 x más a mejor
lo voy a escribir desde el inicio x más
x más 90 grados es igual a 180 grados x
mas x es lo mismo que 2x más 90 es igual
a 180 grados podemos restar 90 grados de
ambos lados así que 2x es igual a 90 y
dividiendo ambos lados entre 2 x es
igual a 45 grados x es igual a 45 grados
y ya terminamos el ángulo a b será la
suma del ángulo de 60 grados más el de
45 grados o sea
a 60 45 da como resultado 105 grados y
ahora vayamos con el último problema que
es el más simple tenemos un triángulo
isósceles esta pierna es igual a esta
otra
este es el ángulo del vértice y ahora
tengo que resolver para b y el truco
aquí es dirás cómo voy a saber dos
ángulos si nada más tengo uno pero como
hicimos en el ejercicio anterior en la
segunda parte del problema que si este
es un triángulo isósceles lo cual ya
sabemos que si es entonces este ángulo
debe de ser igual a este otro ángulo así
que si le llamamos x ya éste también
tendremos que x más x más 36 más 36 es
igual a 180 grados cuando suman las x
obtienes 2x
no voy a saltarme ningún paso en este
punto así que 2x más 36 es igual a 180
después restamos 36 de cada lado
así que 12 x + ops está 2x está un poco
rara así que 2x es igual a 180 menos 36
s 180 le quito 30 me quedan 150 y si
luego 650 le quito 6 me quedan 144 si
144 después dividimos ambos lados entre
2 y me queda x igual a 72 grados así que
esto es igual a 72 grados
y con esto terminamos